Carrie went in and said I'm gonna ask
south since you know Sal's always
goofing on me I'm just gonna go down and
give him an IQ test
you know verbally maybe we can turn it
into a game so Gary did it and he came
back and he said to me first of all he
goes you can't make this a game he
doesn't know [ __ ] it he doesn't know
anything there's no time he answered
correctly once or twice but you should
know that the other thing that's funny
about this is most almost all of these
questions have been taken from quizzes
that sounds given so he should know them
because he came up with the questions
now these are Sal's questions and he
actually research you know I got to Gary
at one point laughed so hard I get it
here in what country did the great
potato famine take place Idaho oh the
great what country Idaho he had a double
wrong answer yeah I mean you wasn't a
country and it wasn't the place where
the potato famine occurring right south
come in here you [ __ ] what country had
the potato famine he said it so quickly
and just went over my head I heard
potatoes and I was reaiiy recently
watched a special on the History Channel
about potatoes and they were discussing
Idaho so peas it and yeah I did I
watched about 10 minutes of yeah okay
and I watched the fascinating show about
potatoes channel once I saw it was
potato
I thought Gary set me up with that
because those questions yes we're almost
the same questions we asked on the those
are the exact same questions we asked
through the ones you wrote and you don't
even know the [ __ ] answer so Gary was
goofing on because they sounded familiar
all right here's Sal taking his test
with Gary what is the capital of
California Los Angeles that's what I
said hmm oh yeah you're kidding
Los Angeles
it's not the capital it isn't no I could
have sworn it was the cat Sacramento
right so the I that one you'd have that
one nope New York Albany that's how I
know no no [ __ ] no kidding idiot and I
don't limit California what do I give a
[ __ ] with the capital it is what two
states border Washington DC I'm bad at
this stuff to sell Don Phil Virginia and
Maryland I know that I lived in
Washington you start to think he's got
he's got something going on what is the
symbol for the Roman numeral 10 you had
have gotten that what did you say like
it I mean here uh I and a V oh you can't
be that [ __ ] stupid and it just to be
is it just the big these V is a five but
wait a minute
oh you know what be in the I what order
do they go the ion of e I think I is one
and then two eyes is two and then three
eyes is three and then use a B's of four
when do you use Roman numerals in your
[ __ ] life and what time is it it's AI
VIII
not you would be institutionalized but
every kid learns but you don't need them
times written when I see X I think you
know what is a female deer call
alright that you must have gone right
what you say doe doe hear what you said
doh oh you got a right yeah okay I think
I was falling asleep during that
question he forgot who invented the
light bulb
no I think I got this ready these were
the three you got right Edison that's
correct
good
playing solitaire that much Gary's doing
okay
I forgot both I would get musi what
country is the Thames River in that's
ridiculous oh come on you should know
that I don't even know it never even
heard of Thames never heard of the
Thames river never Thames River mm-hmm
Thames river the Thames what country is
a Tam's river in country Egypt yeah I
know Nile I figured maybe they have
another river England the Thames all
right okay here we go
which ocean is the state of Hawaii
located in alright there you go you know
that that's a slam dunk yeah that's easy
I'll say goodbye now which ocean is in
Hawaii is out your name which ocean is
the state of Hawaii located in which
ocean is the state of why you mean no
lies on an ocean Atlantica
I mean Atlantic Ocean Hawaii you
struggled with that a little too much
name four continents oh really
I'm getting better at it let me hear
what you said North America South
America Africa
Brazil was a country I used to think it
was Tokyo Mexico from a rap song and
then someone told me that wasn't true
right yeah but Brazil is in I know where
South America you already named that
right but I couldn't think of anything
and well you might as well answer
something right all right who is this
sort of Europe yeah what about it
I've been Italy Robin what's your point
Austrian second person on the moon who
is the second person on the moon now I
knew this but I forgot it that was my
problem
Isaac he knew it all at one point Gary
doesn't count let me hear your answer I
was on our show and it was bud our blood
Dwyers I thought he was a politician you
think you know what John Glenn I was
gonna say bud Glenn final answer what
are you hacker his name Neil Armstrong
bud something bud zelich or something
but how do you know the Commissioner of
baseball walked on the moon
it was bud bud I remember it now now
it's what is it it's Buzz Aldrin Buzz
Aldrin was Lightyear it was Buzz
something he went to the moon to
retrieve a baseball who created the
character Tom Sawyer all right this you
know right you got this one right yeah
because I once said it was rush when
rush rush created the song right right
that's correct and I let the character
itself I think I got this one right see
we said this one was on the show so it
was a Huckleberry Finn
good you got it right Huckleberry Finn
wrote Tom Sawyer about Mark Twain one
fictional character created another
fictional character never hear him
yeah I have heard you used to know that
Taylor but I used to come on Barry Hound
a Bicentennial marks the passing of how
many years you got to write sure okay
Bicentennial would be I believe 20 years
Centennial's ten twice spy Wow shuri's
ten centennial it was ten century is ten
centuries 100 right surprise
Centennial's 10 100 it's 200 years yeah
three you need Robin out what is the
northernmost state in the United States
Washington org
yeah all right no oh you said it it's
not right well obviously to think in
that or California so if it's California
I got it right well now I'm gonna say
California cuz I you don't know what the
country looks like judging by the way
you guys are react maybe it was right
maybe is Washington right but I just
I'll stick with Washington Washington to
get enough okay gun an only United
States that right what sport is played
on a gridiron uh-oh never heard that not
into sports
a gridiron a gridiron a gridiron a
Korean iron sport I'm not into sports
either but I know that soccer soccer
Juche lucky guess football football yeah
I don't see a gridiron then I see a
bunch of straight lines that go a very
gridiron never never then never hmm
gridiron
well what about soccer is a gridiron
is it a grid or if it's similar to a
football field look I don't know you're
having a lot of difficulty you were
asking me things again that I'm not
interested in that well yeah I'm not
interested in football things about
football what newspapers motto is all
the news that's fit to print you knew
that one right yeah would you say New
York Times good okay so you get that far
right New York Times you got four of
them right not too shabby
no way to go your IQ should be around 40